thank you hey youtubers it's Charlie so
this week on The Walking Dead we found
out what happened to the governor after
the end of season 3 he ends up finding a
new family but it seems like the past
might end up repeating itself let's talk
about our favorite moments and then I'll
do my review pound it out number one the
governor is in serious trauma after the
events of season 3 so david morrissey
was on talking dead and he talked about
how the governor was in so much trauma
that he was just gonna keep walking and
just isolate himself from the human race
until he turned into a walker in that
opening montage Martinez leaves him and
obviously it's a huge oh my god moment
at the end of the episode when Martinez
finds him in the pit honestly I think
that if he keeps Megan alive this season
that will be his Redemption so I'm
calling it now if Megan dies he is
totally going all Woodbury again number
2 the governor's new family they bring
him back from the dead with their
neediness he really is trying to avoid
other human beings but Megan is just
such a powerful magnet for him that she
draws him into their family it's really
that moment when Lilly tells the
governor Megan thinks you're her father
that kind of makes him clean himself up
but it's really once they hit the road
together they become this official
family unit obviously the sexy time in
the back of that truck was really just
consummating the marriage speaking of
sexy times though I was kind of getting
that mother-father vibe from lily and
the governor the whole episode
especially after he picked up their real
father and carried him to bed number
three the pit scene so not only was it
intense from a fight perspective it was
also Martinez finding the governor with
Megan so while season for governor is
kind of trying to psychologically kill
season three governor Martinez kind of
brings that all rushing back into his
mind in the teaser for the next episode
we found out that Martinez actually has
a tent city that he's now lording over
like the governor wasn't Woodbury I like
to think of it as tent buri that's just
a big red flag that things might end up
repeating themselves number 4 the chess
set and the story of penny so the
governor uses the chess set to tell
Megan the story of penny and how he
failed to protect her and what ended up
happening as a result of that I thought
the moment when she drew that eye patch
on the king piece and the governor
started laughs crying was just so
intense but be sure to subscribe to get
my 10th buri video next week after the
episode airs it's gonna be another
governor heavy Walking Dead episode but
what did I think of the episode overall
is my favorite episode of The Walking
Dead so far this season mostly just
because David Moore sees
formitz was amazing I give him a solid a
I really enjoyed the montages in the way
the governor did not speak until at
least 10 minutes into the episode I love
the way the episode shows us that the
governor is much more complex now he is
a human being he has emotions he can
love again he can laugh cry at the end
of season three he basically kind of
turned it into this comic book villain
those ridiculous as that is the season
three governor basically had to die and
season for governor is basically trying
to make sure he stays dead but it sounds
like temporary is going to cause some
big problems for season for governor
because remember he's gonna do anything
it takes to save Meghan I'm really
interested to see how Meghan and the
governor's relationship develops are
they going to be like Rick and Carl and
start butting heads or are they going to
have a very loving relationship
obviously Rick and Carl really care
about each other but Carl is basically
kind of gone to the dark side now that
he's started killing but let me know
what your favorite moments from the
episode were and what do you think's
gonna happen with this temporary
situation next week also if there was
anything in the episode that you thought
was really important that I didn't
mention in the video please write it in
the comments and we'll discuss if I
in other news big things happening this
week so Monday is the official start of
Doctor Who week on YouTube I'm doing a
special giveaway as well for the 50th
anniversary DVD you can click here to
learn more about that and you can click
here to get last week's Walking Dead
video there's so much watching high five
see you guys tomorrow